these delicious spicy pancakes are
really great alternative
but more importantly so easy to do
start off by toasting your cumin
[Music]
it's a dry roast basically non-stick pan
just a touch of seasoning
the salt helps to dry out the cumin even
more
and then fresh ginger slice them nice
and thinly
stack it back up and then just slice
nice little thin slices in there
and then keep that bunched up shake the
chilli
removing the seeds will prevent things
getting too hot
now garlic
nice now add olive oil to your toasted
cumin seeds
and then with the garlic ginger and
chili lovely
and it feels strange when you talk about
garlic for breakfast but
the time i spent in india everybody was
eating something savory for breakfast it
was extraordinary
into your bowl and set aside
next the pancake filling add olive oil
to a hot pan
mustard seeds in now they'll start
dancing the minute they hit the pan
then finally slice an onion onions in
a little teaspoon of turmeric sprinkle
that in and look at the color
an instant change leftover potatoes
just slice them
the smell is incredible potatoes in now
spread the potatoes across the pan while
the potatoes stained i want them sort of
absorbing all that really nice turmeric
actually like a sponge season those
potatoes it really helps to bring out
the spice beautifully
they're ready turn off the gas and let
them sit there and absorb all those
flavors
back to the pancake batter add plain
flour to your cooled garlic
chili ginger and cumin seeds a touch
of salt and pepper nothing worse than
the bland
pancake
one whole egg milk hold the jug with one
hand
and whisk we have a secret to get that
really nice smooth paste
but whisk in that egg first and brings
it together
and then you're milking
don't put all the milk in because then
you're gonna get a lumpy pancake mix
and if you put less milk in it really
helps it
not going lumpy look at that
milk here and the secret for me is to
have a nice thin mix
now just a little teaspoon
of oil that helps to bring a nice
crispy edge to the mixture now
just taste
that's the texture pan on the larger the
pan
the better it helps to create a nice
thin even surface i want that
mix going all the way around the pan
before you put the mixture
into the pan make sure you give your
pancake mix a really nice stir
pan it's nice and hot turn down the gas
a touch of olive oil in get that nice
whisk with one hand pan to the mix
in
one and a half ladles and then roll it
around
so it's really nice and thin i want to
see the ginger
the garlic that's what i'm looking for
in there
now back onto the heat it only starts to
remove
from the bottom of the pan and lifts
itself up once it's cooked
these little bubbles confirm that it's
just starting to lift off
the pan a little shake that releases it
and then just shake it to the end
and toss if you haven't got the
confidence tossing
then use a spatula and turn it over now
that's exactly what i want that nice
sort of crisp edge
around the side the colour on the
pancake is so important
now roll it round and just let it slide
out
beautifully
now for the exciting part filling them
take your potatoes just sort of
have a really nice imaginary line
and then just very carefully roll that
nice and tightly tuck it underneath
there
pull it back and roll
useful the delicious pancakes are ready
to eat
but with a simple dipping sauce there'll
be a real treat just
mix chopped coriander with natural
yogurt
that's really nice cooling asian sit
there on the side
and that for me is a great brunch
delicious
spicy pancakes amazing
[Music]
chicken stir-fry with rice noodles some
of the best street food i've ever eaten
was in asia every one of those little
markets was filled with
smells of delicious food that all
centered around an asian staple
noodles learn to cook those properly and
you'll be surprised how quick and easy
it is to knock up a delicious dinner
first off we're gonna soak our noodles
now these are
rice noodles into a bowl and just
pour the hot water over the rice noodles
soak and rehydrate 12
to 15 minutes to soften up if you've got
a wok perfect
if not just a normal sized frying pan
with big sloping sides
pan on get it really nice and hot
chicken breast very lean hardly any fat
on there you've got this little fillet
just slice that off now the secret
to getting it really nice and thin and
to cut it into strips
take your knife keep it nice and flat on
the board
and sort of slice it in half like a sort
of
scallop like that
we call this butterfly in the chicken
take a rolling pin
and nice and gently roll over the
chicken what it does it sort of
flattens it allows you to slice it
even thinner and the thinner the slice
of the chicken
the sort of crispier it gets the quicker
it cooks
slice it in half start slicing
these nice thin slices and the good news
is
one chicken breast can serve two or
three easily
next wash your knife and finally slice
garlic
the thinner the garlic the crispier
this is a young tender
broccoli just slice them down i want a
bite
to the broccoli and normally you sort of
paste the dish
with one-third noodles one-third
vegetables
and one-third of your protein chicken
with a dish that takes literally minutes
to put together it's really important to
get everything organized
everything needs to be at your
fingertips touch
of olive oil get a pan really nice and
ready just starting to smoke
drop the chicken in first
salt pepper open up those little strands
of chicken
nice
[Music]
once you've started to sear off the
chicken get the garlic in
now let that get really nice and crispy
the way to do it is to sort of spread
all the chicken the garlic
up the side of the pan
and see why it's so important to cut the
chicken thin strips because
it colors and cooks at the same time as
well really really crucial
now that garlic's getting really nice
and crispy
broccoli in feels strange putting
raw broccoli in like that normally we
blanch it in boiling water
dry it out but you want that crunch
now soy sauce that helps to season it
but also
stains beautifully soy sauce in
lovely
it's exactly what i want now take that
out
give you a pan a little wipe out
a little teaspoon of olive oil get that
wok
really nicely oiled again
drain your noodles
they're beautiful this is a really
exciting way of finishing
this quick stir fry very classic two
eggs
in whisk up the eggs
and give that a really good whisk
sort of almost spread it
out the side of the pan lightly season
the eggs noodles in
chicken and broccoli in
[Music]
and give that a really nice mix
i want the egg to sort of almost bring
the dish together
that egg's cooked
make sure you've got that nice even
distribution of
chicken broccoli garlic
lovely and then just finish that
fresh lime and then you have a very
simple delicious stir-fry with rice
noodles
[Music]
smoky pork sliders with barbecue sauce
everyone
loves a burger they're a true fast food
original
and that's the exciting thing about
street food you can take an old classic
like that
and reinvent it into something really
exciting
when you think of a burger what you need
is a great sauce and a light
smoky barbecue goes hand in glove with a
great burger
start by finely chopping one onion and
three cloves of garlic
nice hot pan tablespoon of olive oil
onions and garlic into the pan
nice seasoning salt and pepper now the
secret of a good barbecue sauce
is that really important caramelization
to begin with
a nice tablespoon of brown sugar it
darkens
the onions but it really starts to sort
of give that nice syrupy
body to the sauce i put a little bit of
heat in there now
a nice teaspoon of smoked paprika
that's the important part of working
with spices you've got to cook them out
and almost sort of
burn off that rawness especially with a
smoked paprika
that's exactly where i want it to go
onions and garlic
beautifully caramelized
cider vinegar in reduce that down
now i've got a fantastic smoky base to
complete the sauce
i'm making my life really easy and
adding pre-made worcester sauce
and tomato ketchup cook that out for two
to three minutes
now depending on how thick you like the
barbecue sauce
that determines how long you cook it out
for i don't want it to be too
runny but i don't want it too thick
either that's the
consistency we're looking for
lovely turn down the gas
charger seasoning
now take that out it's the kind of sauce
that i like to have sort of
bottled up in the fridge it's great for
sandwiches
but goes brilliantly well with these
sliders homemade
smoky barbecue sauce
[Music]
give the pan a little wipe now start the
mix for the sliders
to give my mix a really interesting
flavor and texture i'm gonna be using
unsmoked back bacon
i travel all over the world
and i spend a lot of time in the states
they know how to make a great slider
pork sliders beef sliders chicken
sliders
and it's almost like a way of having a
burger
but on a much smaller miniature level
a little teaspoon of olive oil i want
that bacon to get really nice and crispy
bacon in this just gives the really nice
sort of
chunky delicious mix i want texture
and pork is perfect for a slider
[Music]
and choppy shallot
slots are a lot sweeter than your normal
white onion
fine fine fine and in
[Music]
now that bacon's getting really nice and
crispy i want a bit of heat in there
a little teaspoon of smoked paprika in
there
when you see these sliders in the states
for one portion there's like
four or five of them little mini one
biters
incredible now take your pork
just open it up and give that a really
nice seasoning
so important you can't season a slider
after you've cooked it it's impossible
so season it nicely
bacon now that's nice and crispy just
take
a little touch kitchen roll and just
drain that off there
[Music]
nice pat that nice and dry
i want all that nice sort of crispiness
in there beautiful mix all that
in take a nice ball
and sort of roll it
size of a golf ball get it nice
and round first and then three fingers
just pat that down don't flatten them
too thin otherwise they overcook and
they go
sort of dry
because sliders are bite-sized burgers
designed to go in small buns you don't
want to make them too big
good
get the pan nice and hot a tablespoon of
olive oil
when a slider is literally that thick
about an inch thick
we're going to take two and a half to
three minutes to each side in
turn them over lovely
once you've turned them tilt the pan and
just spoon
all that juice back into them keep my
mouth watering now
very easy to dry the pork out so just
feeling it now your fingers is
nice and firm it's a little touch of
springiness
in the center i'm happy with those
add your cheese now so it gets nicely
melted
i'm using wedges of smoked cheddar
and it has that nice sort of soury smoky
creaminess
to the slider finally shredded baby gem
lettuce
just take those buns make sure they're
sliced
nice and evenly take your lettuce
be quite generous when the lettuce just
a nice thin slice
of tomato take your burgers
you see that cheese you feed melted
your bbq sauce
place the top on and that is my version
of a slider that is small dynamic but
packed
full of flavor i'll take that over a
hamburger any day
[Music]
you